nos dicen que una onda transversal viaja
a la derecha en una cuerda dos puntos se
indican en la cuerda esos puntos se
indican como p y q en los diagramas la
siguiente figura muestra la cuerda en un
instante en el tiempo en el instante que
se muestra el punto p tiene un
desplazamiento máximo y el punto que no
tiene desplazamiento del equilibrio en
cada punto pq dibuja una flecha que
indica la dirección de la velocidad
instantánea para cada punto si cualquier
punto tiene velocidad cero escribe v
igual a cero junto al punto pausa en el
vídeo y traten de encontrar la respuesta
por su cuenta antes de que lo resolvamos
juntos pensemos en la rapidez
instantánea del punto p y para eso
analicemos lo que ocurre a ambos lados
del punto p si analizamos este punto a
la derecha y nos preguntamos qué es lo
que le ocurre un instante después en el
tiempo nos damos cuenta que la onda está
viajando en esta dirección así que un
momento después la onda se va a ver así
este punto a la derecha está en el
proceso de bajar y qué pasa con este
punto a la izquierda de este punto en un
instante posterior va a estar más alto
se mueve hacia arriba y el punto p
en este momento se encuentra en lo más
alejado posible de la posición de
equilibrio un instante después se pasa
de estar abajo a moverse hacia arriba
por lo que en este momento de máximo
desplazamiento de la posición de
equilibrio el punto que tiene velocidad
cero lo escribimos que le pasa al punto
que ya dibujamos como se ve la onda un
instante después el punto q va a estar
aquí arriba es decir que se mueve hacia
arriba si dibujamos su vector velocidad
se verá así veamos el siguiente inciso
la siguiente figura muestra la cuerda en
el mismo instante que en el inciso
anterior en cada uno de los puntos p y q
dibuja una flecha que indique la
dirección de la aceleración instantánea
de cada punto si cualquier punto tiene
aceleración cero escribe igual a cero
junto al punto de nuevo los invito a que
pausa en el vídeo y traten de resolver
este inciso una forma de pensar en esto
es ver que todos los puntos alrededor de
p de hecho todos los puntos en esta
parte van a tener una aceleración neta
hacia arriba incluso este punto que se
mueve hacia abajo y tiene una velocidad
hacia abajo
esta velocidad hacia abajo disminuye
conforme se acerca a pep y luego se
invierte convirtiéndose en velocidad
hacia arriba que aumenta cada vez más
conforme se acerca a este punto así que
todos los puntos en esta parte tienen
una aceleración neta hacia arriba
incluyendo el punto pp este punto tiene
velocidad instantánea cero pero justo en
ese momento pasa de una velocidad hacia
abajo a una velocidad hacia arriba por
lo que su aceleración neta es hacia
arriba ahora veamos el punto q algo
interesante que podemos notar es que
toda esta región de aquí abajo tiene
aceleración hacia arriba y todo lo que
está aquí arriba tiene aceleración hacia
abajo de igual forma todo lo que está
acá abajo tiene aceleración hacia arriba
el punto que se encuentra justamente en
esa transición donde pasa de una
aceleración hacia abajo a una
aceleración hacia arriba por lo que
justo en este punto y en este instante
la aceleración es cero lo escribimos
veamos otro inciso la siguiente figura
representa una cuerda en el tiempo t
igual a cero
mismo instante que se muestra en la
parte a cuando el punto p está en el
máximo desplazamiento de la posición de
equilibrio el punto que uno se muestra
para simplificar la gráfica en la
siguiente cuadrícula dibuja la cuerda en
el tiempo posterior t igual a t
mayúscula entre 4 donde t mayúscula es
el periodo de la onda de nuevo los
invito a que pausa en el vídeo y traten
de dibujar esta gráfica por su cuenta
para identificar el periodo de la onda
tenemos que ubicar una longitud de onda
completa una forma de hacer esto es
identificar un punto en la onda y ver
cuánta distancia se recorre antes de
encontrar el mismo punto más adelante en
la onda aquí en la onda sube luego baja
y llegamos a este punto que quizá
podrían pensar que es el mismo punto
pero no es así ya que en el punto
anterior
la onda subía y en este punto la onda
baja así que no es el mismo punto la
onda baja y vuelve a subir y ahora si
llegamos al mismo punto
esta es una longitud de onda completa en
este caso mide 24 centímetros después de
una cuarta parte del período
la onda recorre una cuarta parte de esta
longitud
es una de estas secciones de aquí lo que
vamos a hacer es dibujar la misma onda
pero en lugar de comenzar en el inicio
comenzamos acá una cuarta parte de la
longitud de onda a la derecha dibujamos
la misma onda pero desplazada una cuarta
parte de la longitud de onda la onda se
ve algo así si vemos la siguiente parte
de la pregunta dice en el dibujo que
hiciste arriba dibuja un punto para
indicar la posición del punto p en la
cuerda en el tiempo te iguala t
mayúscula entre 4 y señala dicho punto
con la letra p recordemos en donde se
encontraba el punto p originalmente
estaba justo entre los 12 y los 24
centímetros o lo que es lo mismo a los
18 centímetros en la nueva gráfica del
punto p está justo aquí así que desde
que t es igual a 0 hasta que te es igual
al periodo dividido entre 4 me pasó de
estar aquí a estar acá el último inciso
dice ahora considera la onda en el
tiempo te iguala t mayúscula es decir un
período completo determina la distancia
recorrida no el desplazamiento del punto
p entre los tiempos de igual a cero y te
iguala t mayúscula
de nuevo pausa en el vídeo y traten de
pensar en esto ya vimos que cuando t
mayúscula es igual a cero el punto p se
encuentra aquí qué va a pasar después de
un periodo completo pues el punto p va a
subir toda esta distancia hasta llegar a
los ocho centímetros en el eje y después
va a bajar toda esta distancia hasta
llegar de nuevo a los menos ocho
centímetros donde se encontraba antes si
nos preguntaran el desplazamiento
diríamos que es cero ya que el punto
regreso al lugar donde estaba al inicio
pero nos preguntan la distancia vemos
que recorrió 816 centímetros hacia
arriba y después recorrió 16 centímetros
abajo por lo que la distancia total
recorrida es de 32 centímetros con eso
terminamos y nos vemos en el siguiente
vídeo